Yes,
Gary Clark Jr welcome to the show.
Thank you.
How are you?
I'm great man.
I'm great.
I owe a Ari Shaffir to connect me to
you.
He's the one that connected me.
Yeah,
he,
he uh,
he goes,
check this out.
He played a num for me.
I go,
who is this motherfucker?
Yeah.
And then from there on,
I've been a Gary Clark Jr respect to
our,
I appreciate it.
Yeah,
man.
What's going on man?
Oh Man.
Just trying to figure out la I came out
here in July and just kind of figuring
it out man is not Austin.
Not at all.
No,
not at all.
But I'm starting to get a little bit,
you know,
familiar in Austin's a couple of hours
away on an airplane so I can figure it
out.
Um,
but yeah,
man,
I'm,
I'm glad you,
you hit me up.
Uh,
the um,
uh,
honey honey crew.
Yeah,
that's the one I like pop that off.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Suzanne connected us.
Awesome.
They're great.
They're good people,
man.
I love those guys.
Yeah.
I ran into them at,
um,
uh,
bridge school benefit,
Neil young thing.
And so it's good to reconnect.
First Time I came out here,
we did a Gig with them.
Oh really?
Yeah.
So what made you move from Austin,
which is like one of the best spots in
the world.
If you could pull it off to California,
which is still one of the best spots in
the world if you can pull it off,
but so much more complex,
much more bullshit.
So much marty ego.
So much more traffic.
So much more actors.
Right.
That's true,
man.
That's very true.
But um,
I spent some time in New York City.
I spent my whole life in Austin,
always wanting to come out west and we
figured out what it's like,
you know?
And um,
so I got the opportunity to do it.
So I'm just how you're checking it out
being in a few months.
Oh,
so he's,
there was no like specific like pulling
reason.
You said let me just try La.
No,
me and my girl just decided we spend
some time out here.
I like it.
I like moves like that,
man.
I think about doing those all the time.
But my wife is so not into that because
I moved that bitch at the top of my
mountain at one time and she almost fell
off the club.
Oh,
for real drive of the snow dog got
killed by a mountain lion.
It was a punch of shit happened.
Yeah.
Be My,
I was in heaven.
Loved it.
Damn.
Eh.
Speaking of mountain lions,
I heard they're like creeping around
over here.
There's quite a few of them.
Yeah.
There you can't hunt them in California.
So they have no natural predators other
than cars.
Right.
And there's people that think that's a
good idea because they keep the deer
population in check.
There's a good argument for that cause
we don't have lyme disease.
It's very little lyme disease in
California.
And one of the reasons for that is,
is that not that many deer,
especially around here,
whereas if you're on the east coast,
the east coast right now has a real lyme
disease epidemic because these deer
overpopulated and overpopulated dear
means you don't get enough food and
they're more susceptible to disease.
And fucking lyme disease is the big one.
Ticks these ticks with lyme disease.
I know a bunch of people from the east
coast that have got lyme disease.
It's fucking bad.
It's big down in Texas too.
There's deer everywhere.
Yeah,
I guess that's a good thing.
But I'd be freaked out if I walked out.
You know,
most of the time,
don't have to worry.
Most of the time they're going after
cats and dogs and shit like that.
They killed a lot of rabbits and small
animals and deer.
They've decimated the deer population.
They kill most of the deer,
either coyotes get them or mountain
lions get,
I'm like,
when I see deer in my neighborhood,
it's pretty unusual.
Whereas if I go back east,
like,
uh,
you know,
like I have a buddy lives on a farm in,
um,
well he owns a farm in Wisconsin,
this fucking deer everywhere there.
So that's the type of place where you
got to worry about ticks.
Fuck that.
You worried about mountain lines?
I mean,
uh,
anything that could like take a chunk.
Yeah.
Let me,
I'm a little bit worried about what do
you live?
Uh,
I won't say Pacif specifically.
Yeah.
And live somewhere hilly?
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
I'll,
I'll give you an a flat lands where the
people are all,
they did kill one in someone's backyard
and Santa Monica two years ago.
Yeah.
Fucking Santa Monica.
Do you remember that?
It was a big one too.
It was like 150 pound cat and some
dude's yard just chilling,
sleeping in his yard.
I can't do that.
Talking about something,
I was like,
I freaked out.
I just don't,
I just don't fuck with nature of that.
You know what I mean?
I'm not a,
you know,
I love that.
You know,
I,
I don't,
it's,
I respect it,
you know,
me too.
So,
um,
and you know,
I'm not really into getting eaten,
but just that phrase,
I don't fuck with nature.
We have a picture you with a guitar
point to get the cabbage and says,
I don't fuck with nature.
Yeah.
Right.
Oh Man,
I didn't,
you know what I mean?
I know exactly what you mean.
Yeah.
It's dangerous man out there in the
wilderness and you know,
this is a big,
cities are great.
You don't.
People think that somehow or another if
you love nature that you don't love
cities.
I love everything.
Cities is this beauty and everything.
You can't be close minded.
Yeah,
I agree.
I mean coming from where I'm from,
the Austin,
this city and in this nice land around
it,
so I'd like to jump back and forth and
be involved in both,
but I will not fuck with mountain.
I don't mess with sharks.
Yeah,
I'm down with that.
My kids are going to start taking
surfing lessons because little five and
seven they want to take surfing lesson.
I'm like,
that's like a bite like one bite.
Like you don't even survive if you get
bitten by a shark.
If you're five you serve.
No,
I don't fuck with sharks either.
That's it.
I would share.
I would serve the would figure out some
sort of bite proof suit for sure.
You know,
that's what's holding me back.
Yeah,
that's definitely what's holding me
back.
I would have a bite proof suit and then
I would want a big ass knife strapped to
my thigh.
So for shark did bite me and it didn't
get through.
I just fucking fighting as well.
The fucker take that.
Take it bitch.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I hear Ya.
Well there's a lot of them over here
too.
There's more sharks for sure.
Then there are mountain lions,
I think.
What did I say?
For sure if I think,
but when you fly over California,
like there's a lot of like helicopters
that fly over like the Malibu coast.
They take video footage of pig has great
white sharks all the time that are just
a couple of hundred yards away from
people surfing.
Yeah,
no thanks.
Thanks.
That's a lot of helicopters out here in
la in general.
Yeah.
Wow.
Well,
because it's a big flat area and there's
a lot of criminals.
It's a good way to catch people put
spot.
It's weird when you watch it,
you know,
they call them ghetto birds.
It's weird when you watch him in,
the helicopters are flying over and they
had a spotlight on somebody.
You start feeling guilty.
You haven't even done shit.
And uh,
you know,
know I'm particularly sensitive,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
Especially,
it wasn't a matter of town what it
today.
Damn it.
How long have you been doing music,
man,
man?
Um,
I've been playing guitar since 96.
Uh,
I always kind of wanted one and my folks
were,
I had a habit of quitting what I
started,
you know,
like I played baseball for a little bit.
I tried to do martial arts for a little
bit.
I try to do,
um,
basketball,
football and none of it kind of stuck.
How would always kind of go back to
music.
So finally in [inaudible] 96,
I just,
I got in and quit caring about anything.
You know,
I got a guitar discovered urban,
I was like,
and that was about it.
Did you take lessons or did you self
taught?
Um,
I didn't take lessons formerly.
Like I didn't pay anybody for lessons.
My probably should at this point.
When my friend of mine,
he [inaudible] say she had a guitar and
she had a band and she earned,
her band would practice all the time.
So I would hear him.
So I would go over there and check it
out and I'll take my guitar and she
would show me,
you know,
like a 12 bar blues,
kind of like a Jimmy Reed shuffle type
thing or like a power chord,
rock and roll thing,
whatever.
And um,
so that was kind of how I first started.
And I rented books.
I went to the school library and my
middle school library and just rented
like how to play guitar.
Wow.
Watch this TV show,
Austin city limits that came on,
I know Saturday.
So I used to just sit there and figure
it out,
you know,
why record the tapes and go back and
figure it out.
So it was essentially like the first
thing that you really connected to that
you stuck with.
Yeah.
What was it about playing guitar?
Uh,
I think the thing for me was
mmm,
I mean I love music and I mean the
guitar for me was the instrument that
could,
it could paint so many different colors.
It was very versatile,
you know,
it can be loud,
aggressive.
Okay.
Be Sweet.
Beautiful.
Um,
and,
uh,
I just thought if I could get my hands
on one of those,
I would,
you know,
try and push it to the limit and,
and I really figured it out.
MMM.
You just play with like the full
spectrum.
It's different than playing an electric
guitar.
For me it seemed more there was more
options than like a playing drums or
playing the trumpet or something.
What I mean with toys and you know,
yeah.
Things like that.
So that was it.
I don't know,
I'm still trying to figure it out.
I'm as interested in it,
you know,
20 years later as I was,
then that means you got the right thing.
Yeah,
I definitely found it so fortunately
that way.
That's one of the hardest things for
kids,
right.
When you're a young kid and you don't
really know what you want to do with
your life and your,
your whole future just looks like just
confusing sometimes.
The hardest thing is finding something
that really rings your bell.
Finding something.
So for you it seems like there was a
bunch of different other options.
It didn't get groups,
didn't really click.
And then the guitar just that was it.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
baseball was a terrible hitter.
I was pretty fast.
Basketball was tall,
but I was stan,
so,
you know,
put me in a post and I would get pushed
out by these huge guys and I got tired
of my coach going,
Goddamn a junior when he got to quit
being a bitch.
So,
uh,
you know,
it was just just with music,
it would just,
it just kinda clicked.
It was something for me.
What martial law should you do?
A,
I tried to Quanta.
Um,
yeah.
Perfect bill for that.
Yeah,
I just didn't have the patients at the
time.
I really didn't.
I wish I stuck with it,
you know?
Um,
but I,
yeah,
I,
I didn't have the patience or the
discipline.
I didn't want to,
you know,
be focused and I wanted to,
there's something out the window,
I want to go run and jump out the
window,
go ride bikes or whatever it was.
No,
they call that add.
But I call that just being a fucking
person and curious.
Like there's a lot of shit that doesn't
occupy your attention and you're
supposed to make it occupy your
attention.
Right.
You know?
Well you keep yourself pretty busy.
Yeah.
But like,
like guitar obviously occupied your
attention.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like I don't believe in add in a
lot of senses and a lot of ways.
I think there's obviously some people
that have like a mental issue,
but I think for most people what they're
calling add is being bored.
You just bored like school.
How fucking boring in school school's
terribly boring.
Yeah.
I was terrible.
I was terrible too.
I spent a lot of my time.
Yeah,
you should stay in school kids.
A lot of time showing up to that
building and then immediately turning
back around and going and doing what
interested me.
Yeah,
and look at you now,
mother fucker.
I'm doing all right.
But it's finding that thing and then
going after it.
That's what it is.
And what school does is teaches you that
the future is bleak in a lot of ways.
Obviously it educates you and obviously
for people that that go on to choose
some sort of an academic career,
it's imperative.
Right?
But for a lot of people that pushing you
to pay attention to shit you don't want
to pay attention to,
it stifles creativity.
It's just not the best way for people to
learn.
It gives you like this horrible feeling
about the future.
Like you feel like an outsider.
Yeah,
I didn't feel comfortable at all.
I mean I was constantly trying to figure
out what,
what,
why,
why am I spending so much time every day
doing this,
you know,
and uh,
I just had other interests.
I mean,
I,
I believe that it does work for some
people and,
and people need it,
but just for me,
the type of person that I,
that I am,
I was just like already know what I want
to be doing.
I wish I could spend my time doing all
the things.
Alternative schooling wasn't really an
option for me or anything at that point.
So,
um,
is this an Austin you were growing up?
I grew up at us in the school system
there.
It's pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
It was good.
But I felt like I could,
you know,
I would much rather have four hours in
music class and right.
Doing something else.
So I'm not really knocking the system.
It was just mine,
my interest,
you know,
and uh,
I think it's almost impossible to find a
style of teaching or a,
a course of study that's going to be
really interesting and fascinating to
every kid.
Right.
It's the problem I think is shoving kids
in classes and trying to educate them
like they're a product like a factory,
you know?
I just don't think,
I don't think the way we do it as the
best way to do it.
I don't have a better solution,
so I have to shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
I don't either.
Um,
yeah,
we had to read that book.
Brave new world kind of Ooh,
trip me out.
Yeah.
Uh,
I know if I'm ready for that,
but yeah,
dude,
you don't have a solution either of
them.
There's a cadillac that have in one of
your videos.
Is that your car?
I know God.
No.
See the hate when that shit happens.
When those stylists,
they hook you up with a car that I'm
like,
Damn,
Gary Clark Jr drives a dope ass old
cadillac.
Nah,
I drove a,
I drive a 94 Cadillac that I think is
pretty dope with the director of the
video is like no,
it's a piece of shit.
He got this,
you got this girl,
um,
uh,
to bring her a ride.
And um,
what year was that one?
I think it was like a 66.
Who was so slick.
It was like if Gary Clark Jr really
drives that Cadillac.
There it is.
Look at that mother fucker.
Yeah man.
Dude,
you look like you just stepped off the
set of superfly.
I know,
I know.
And you know,
and then I got back to my house and then
like got in my car to go to do whatever
I had to do and I was like,
man,
this is not the same shit but fucking
car is sick.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
How did you get to drive it?
I'm not like a hungry,
no,
no.
I drove it up and down that street like
I like seven times.
It's so depressing what they do,
man.
They've,
but they nailed it.
They found the perfect car for your
music.
Yeah,
I know.
Like that's a soulful car.
That car has soul to it.
It's got like a,
it's a piece of a history.
It's a,
it's a piece of art,
you know?
Yeah.
Know you're making me feel really
terrible.
But you're a success with musician,
man.
Everybody knows who you are.
Go out and get it suite six to six.
Yeah.
Cause I don't drive that much anymore.
I spend so much time on the road man.
Right.
So,
you know,
uh,
someday I have a nice little collection
someday,
someday in the,
in the mind you got,
so you drive,
you drive a cadillac though.
Yeah.
Escalate or something.
No,
no,
no.
I got one.
Yeah,
I got this,
this 94 Cadillac Deville when I was 19 I
still got it.
Really?
Yeah,
man.
Even cooler because that one's kind of a
poser car and a lot of ways his car in
the photo,
like you know the beautiful 66 you can't
really take that thing anywhere.
Look at that.
What are you gonna take it?
You got to park it there.
Some asshole with Volvo.
Volvo's going to open up the car door on
you,
you know?
Yeah.
I would struggle to parallel park.
That thing you're going to get looks
from those shitheads and Prius's the
self righteous moral high ground people.
They're going to look at you.
Do you have any idea?
Is it worth it?
Is it really worth it?
You're killing seals.
He's going to look at your shitty.
Yeah,
so look at the fucking hubcaps or the
rims on that.
It must be in rhythm.
So those aren't hubcaps that some
aftermarket shit and those beautiful
white wall tires.
But a lot of ways like your car is
actually cooler because your car is like
a car that no one,
no one gets.
No one wants to try it.
I they don't get it to try to like look
cool.
Like that car is such a,
I'm getting it to look cool car that
it's not even yours.
And they used it for you in a music
video to make you look bad ass.
Right.
But your car is actually more badass
because it's your first car from the
time when you're 19 you still have it
right and you drive it.
But that's pretty cool though.
Fuck yeah,
that's cool.
One day.
Thanks for making me feel better though.
Well,
you're more,
you're more authentic.
See like if you were like going way out
of your way to own that car,
but it was breaking down all the time
and it was fucking up and that will be
kind of silly.
That was your only car,
right?
Yeah.
But I'm thinking about my car breaking
down on
does.
It does.
Yeah,
it did.
Well,
you got to get one of them new ones.
Those new cadillacs at fucking space
ships.
I saw some new thing though.
We're working on.
Yeah,
they have a bunch of new ones now.
Cadillacs,
got some incredible cars.
Now they're finally,
they like something happened in like the
late nineties,
early two thousands.
They started turning around and now they
have pretty amazing cars.
Hello.
Well,
I know you need like a CTSV one.
Those I've been in,
I've been in a bubble and musical bubble
in a musical bubble and then,
uh,
baby bubble,
double bubble.
Yeah.
So I'm two babies,
like being,
I'm getting out,
I'm here.
I am.
So yeah,
that's like a two baby bubble,
right?
Because music is kind of like you're
giving birth to an album.
Does that make sense?
Yeah,
definitely.
That's how I feel about it.
Uh,
yeah.
Do you knew one that you came out with
in September?
It sounds different than the other ones,
but cool.
But in they're like,
it's almost like you were,
you know,
I'm like,
you're taking different chances or
you're,
you're experimenting with like different
sounds.
Hmm.
Well,
yeah,
I was telling Jamie when I came in here
and I was like,
uh,
before I recorded,
my first album on a major black and
blue,
I was living in Texas and I had a live
room where I had drums,
keys,
bass rig,
guitar,
all set up.
And then another room I had my
turntables,
drum machines,
uh,
keyboards all like put it like I'm going
to this pro tools session.
So I was just making demos and sampling
records and just kind of doing whatever
I wanted to,
wanted to do.
And,
um,
so for this,
yeah,
for this latest record,
I just kind of wanting to get back into
that space and experiment and vibe and
challenge myself musically.
You know,
it's like just playing out on the road
every,
every night or whatever for a few years,
kind of playing the same songs and,
you know,
trying to,
uh,
bring new life of those in a certain way
was different than,
um,
I felt like I was kind of stagnant.
Like I wasn't playing drums like I was
every day.
I wasn't playing bass like I was.
And I,
you know,
I want to be a musician,
I want to be all around musician and
push it to the limit.
So for this latest record,
I just was able to do that and spend a
lot of time and uh,
so yeah,
it does sound different.
It's all me playing,
you know,
most of the instruments as opposed to
the last one was a band.
Oh Wow.
How many,
how many different instruments you play?
Um,
I guess I wouldn't say I play them.
I mess around and some of it works.
But I played drums,
I played bass keys.
Um,
harmonica,
percussion.
Yeah,
just kind of the foundation.
And did you take lessons for any of
these,
but formal lessons?
Like once you started rolling and you
started becoming a musician?
No,
no,
no.
I was,
I was a choir boy in middle school.
Well,
yeah.
Yeah,
I got a hard time for the basketball
team.
Just man,
they used to give me a hard time.
So that was the formal training that I
had.
I learned,
you know,
scales and notes like that,
but so you can read music,
not really.
You put,
you can put it,
you can put a chart
in front of me and I'll,
okay,
no idea.
I have no idea.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
Musician,
like you're,
you're a real musician.
You have like records you with a record
label.
I see your shit and I saw you shared at
the airport once a music video that was
playing on a television.
They're like,
you're a professional musician,
but I don't read music.
No,
but it's like me being a comedian.
That doesn't,
right?
No,
it's worse.
It's like me being an author who doesn't
read
books,
who can't read books.
Does that make sense?
No,
no.
Jamie says no guy behind me.
He didn't play with Hendrix.
You Dj.
I got to take that picture down and put
a real one up.
Unfortunately,
that's not his real a mugshot photo.
It's a real photo obviously,
but that's not the actual four.
They fucked me,
man.
I bought this shit.
That's Rosa parks.
Real mugshot photo though.
The Elvis one is real,
but it's not really a mugshot.
It was when he went to visit Nixon in
the White House or took a photo of him
for goof.
But that's just a classic picture of
Hendrix.
And then they put his actual mugshot
photo,
uh,
underneath it.
He's real photo was him with like
shorter hair.
It looked more like a classic Afro.
That's like Jimi Hendrix experience when
they had those white dudes behind him
with the big Afros as well.
Yeah.
That's his real photo.
Yes.
See,
you see the,
um,
the image is correct for the Mugshot,
like for his name,
but that's the wrong photo.
They fucked me.
Somebody had to tell me thank you ever
told me some,
some dude online.
Let me know.
Hey Dude,
that ain't the real one.
Fuck,
fuck right assholes.
They just got a good one.
I mean,
that looks like the perfect arrest photo
of Jimmy Hendrix.
And he also has this looking at his
face.
Like,
I can't believe these motherfuckers who
arrested me.
Where's the other one?
He,
he's got the look like,
Oh shit,
I just got fucking arrested for heroin.
That's a different look.
You know,
that's,
that's the,
ah,
fuck.
I can't let,
God dammit I get tea.
I take the picture man.
Shit,
Shit.
I'm a obviously a huge Hendrix fan and I
can't bring myself to read.
He had a former bodyguard that wrote
some book that claims that his ex
manager had him killed.
That Hendricks manager not only had him
killed but even had him kidnapped at one
point in time just so he could rescue
him cause hendricks is going to leave
his manager.
They also,
this guy also alleges that hendricks
manager killed hendricks girlfriend who
was with him at the time that he died.
Like she jumped off a building in Soho,
I believe.
Um,
and they,
they think that they threw her off that
building because she knew that this guy
had killed Hendrix.
I Dunno.
Either.
You,
so you did read the no,
no,
I can't bring myself to it.
I can't either because I don't want to
get down some rabbit hole that I can't
prove.
But this guy who was a,
he was a musician himself,
he was with the animals,
I believe.
You know,
um,
what was the one hit song they had?
Um,
I forget the song,
but he was a,
he was actually a musician himself and
it didn't work out for him.
And he started working as a bodyguard
for,
um,
for Hendricks and working with this
manager character who was apparently
like universally known as like a really
bad guy,
like real shady.
Like back in the day of music,
you were dealing with a lot of mob
characters,
right?
A lot of organized crime characters.
A lot of creepy,
like a lot of dangerous people like Phil
Spector.
That crazy.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Yep.
I mean,
it doesn't get any crazier than that
guy.
And if you don't know who Phil Spector
is,
you'll google him and you go,
well,
how come his hair looks like this in one
picture?
And it has hair.
Like he wore a bunch of crazy wigs when
he got arrested for shooting a woman in
the mouth just a few years ago and a
killer,
he picked up some woman at a bar on
sunset,
took it back to his mansion and shot her
in the mouth.
Yeah,
he was crazy.
But that guy was famous for like putting
guns in people's mouths.
He was a famous for pulling guns on
people and apparently it was just a big
part of the music business back then.
It was organized crime and just
dangerous people with ties to organized
crime.
And this guy who managed Hendrix,
Hendrix apparently wanted to leave him
and as he was on his way
out,
that's when this guy had the Hendrix
kidnapped.
This is what they are alleging in the
book and I believe it's been confirmed
that Hendricks was kidnapped and this
guy did,
um,
get him rescued the idea.
He had him kidnapped so he could rescue
them.
So He'd say,
Look Dude,
you need me.
I just fucking saved your life.
That's crazy.
Fucking up shit.
Crazy fucked up shit.
Yeah.
I don't know if I could dig
deep and read.
Yeah,
exactly.
They don't want to go.
There I go.
I would like to know the truth,
but I don't,
I almost don't want to go down the
rabbit hole.
His name was Mike Jeffrey and apparently
he was also a demolition expert and
assassin for the British.
Am I six before he was a manager.
Whoa.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Okay.
I got it.
It sounds fascinating now.
I got some shit to read this weekend.
Definitely.
I don't know why I haven't come across
anything like that.
Music business you get kind of compared
to him now in a lot of ways.
Why is that?
Is it just because you're a handsome
young black man was very good at the
guitar?
I think it's cause I'm handsome.
What is it?
What are we,
I think that's what it is,
but that's what it is.
But you do have like,
um,
like in num num is a perfect example of
that.
You have,
that's a,
it's an unusual sound.
You know those guitar riffs that you
have in that and it's uh,
I can't like that.
There's certain sounds so you go,
oh,
like that's a carry karch sound like
that sounds like,
like Hendrix,
there was a bunch of Hendrix songs where
you can hear like Voodoo child,
a Nigga.
Okay,
well that's fucking Hendrix.
You know,
like people can,
they can catch that sort of unique sound
in a world of people riffing in a world
of people making these amazing sounds
with guitars.
Occasionally someone can isolate like
particular sounds like of course ac DC.
Right,
right,
right.
You know,
you listen to ACDC,
it's like almost immediately,
you know,
it's an ACDC song,
but you've got your own thing going on.
Uh,
yeah,
I think so.
Um,
but I,
I can understand that Hendrick's
comparisons,
I mean fuzzy guitars over heavy riffs,
black guy doing it,
you know,
um,
yeah,
I get it.
It used to bother me,
but I'm not mad at it.
I mean,
it's like he's great.
Yeah.
I want to be great,
you know?
And if people have thrown your name and
the same sentences greats in a positive
way,
I'll take it and just keep practicing.
Perfect attitude,
man.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's perfect.
What kind of music are you into?
Um,
what am I into?
Uh,
uh,
at the,
I'm into like,
uh,
s southern hip hop.
Really?
Yeah.
Like,
uh,
speaking at cadillacs and stuff.
I used to drive around and I don't know
if y'all got like the chopped and
screwed the stuff,
but like I used to listen to Dj screw
and,
um,
what's the chop to unscrewed stuff?
What's your house?
It's like,
it's like,
it's like the music.
It's like,
it's just slowed down and kind of,
you know,
like they'll take a lyric and like on a
turntable and chop it up and like repeat
something or whatever.
And it's really kind of a headache,
trippy stuff.
So I used to,
you know,
I listened to that all the time and uh,
so I just recently kind of got back into
listening to,
um,
you know,
things like that.
Like I got Paul Walls record slim thug,
loosen the big credit.
Um,
so just like Texas southern,
I don't know if it was me,
what to do with braces,
right?
He's got a grill,
the grill,
sorry,
I get confused.
Oh Shit.
That's a little bit different.
But yeah,
so I've been,
I've been listening,
I don't know if it's like Texas always
has braces,
braces,
and so what does it,
how does he eat corn on the cob?
That's my question.
I don't know.
I think those come out.
I think you take him out.
Yeah.
That's like some shitty wears like a
dental dam or no,
that's when you eat some dangerous,
that's a dental dance floor,
right?
It's for eating dangerous pussy.
That is a,
which by the way,
if you use that,
kill yourself.
If you're even thinking about going down
on a girl and you have to throw a
fucking tarp over at first,
he really,
you've made some terrible choices and
you probably never going to recover this
stop.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh Man.
All right.
Come on.
That's where it's at.
Will you kiss her?
But you won't eat her pussy.
Stop.
Yeah.
He uses chaos.
Gone too far.
Did you live in your life completely
wrong.
You need an intervention,
psychedelics or something?
Psychedelics?
Um,
yeah.
It's been a long time for me on that.
Oh,
really?
We can,
we can help you.
Jamie can,
he knows people,
right?
No,
passing off on him.
He kept to the case.
The cops are listening.
Listening.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
it's getting closer and closer to being
legal,
man.
I mean,
they just,
uh,
they just released some new,
new financial stats on the amount of
money that they're making off medical
marijuana once,
if they can,
if they can really establish that this
is like a nationwide way that people can
make a ton of money off taxes and turn
economies around it.
They haven't Denver,
I mean,
they turn the economy in Denver around.
Do you perform there a lot?
Um,
I'm not a lot.
I'm trying to get there more.
Yeah.
But uh,
yeah,
it doesn't belly up a couple of times
and done some,
uh,
did red rocks out there?
Oh Man.
Yeah,
a couple of times.
A lot of beautiful venue.
That is,
Huh?
Yeah,
it's great.
But I mean,
the vibe is killed.
It's a great experience as far as every,
all that,
well,
the Denver vibe is like,
it's like some new American Amsterdam
type shit or something.
It's crazy.
It's this amazing city now.
I mean,
it went from being this cowboy city that
was filled with really cool people to
somewhere,
I think in the early two thousands,
I don't remember what the year it was.
They decriminalized marijuana in the
city of Denver.
They just went,
fuck it.
We're just not arresting anybody for it.
It's a stupid,
they like you.
You could have all your state laws you
can have on your national laws.
We're just not going to arrest people
for it.
Okay,
we're done.
And so they would tell us that when
we're working.
They're like,
what?
I'm like,
yeah,
they don't care.
You could smoke pot.
And I'm like,
really?
Like yeah,
they won't arrest you.
They publicly said they won't arrest
you.
So there was,
that was the first stepping point.
And then when it became legal and now
they make more money from it than they
do from alcohol,
which is incredible.
They make more money in tax because the
taxes are very high.
Like it's 39% taxes for recreational
marijuana.
But nobody gives a fuck because it's
still way cheaper than alcohol.
Like you could get $10 for the weed and
be fucked up for the entire day.
That's true.
You know,
I mean,
you take one $5 pot candy,
so what?
It's 39% taxes.
What does that,
so that makes it,
what,
eight bucks?
So then you,
then you take that one pot candy and
your barbecued,
right?
That's one jamison.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's one drink.
It's like not even close.
So like economically it's a great thing
for the city.
And once,
once that sort of sets in that we've
been lied to about that.
And then all these new studies are
coming out,
um,
about the,
the benefits of a different psychedelics
for ptsd.
A John Hopkins did a longterm study on
silicide been,
they're doing new studies on psilocybin
with people that are terminally ill and
uh,
people that are,
they're getting towards the end of life,
you know,
older folks and it's just a alleviated
tension and worry and fear of death and
in a beautiful way.
And then they'll realize like,
hey,
you know,
we can profit off this shit.
Like this is,
this is more money that can be generated
to help the school systems,
the fix the roads to hire new cops to,
to change the way,
you know,
we,
uh,
address and interface with these things
and stop,
stop criminalizing them.
Right.
Yeah,
I totally agree.
I'm not as educated on all that as I
would like to be,
but I feel like,
um,
you know,
once that door gets opened up,
yeah,
it'd be a lot more beneficial than it
is.
Uh,
he said to be,
you know,
hurting.
Yeah.
Well,
we're just stuck in the momentum of an
ignorant past.
It's what it is.
You know what I'm saying?
What,
what kind of psychedelics have you
experimented
with Gary Clark,
Jr I spent,
are you looking at,
I just started sweating.
I looked at it.
It could be a cop.
Yeah.
I was like,
oh man.
man,
when I walk into,
hold on a minute.
Yeah.
I spend a little time,
I love a psychedelic mushrooms.
It's been a long time,
but,
um,
I,
I definitely have a experiment.
I feel like I've gained some things from
those experiences.
Uh,
that's about it does,
that's a good one though.
Mushrooms and weed.
Yeah,
both.
Excellent combination.
I love it.
Well,
keep,
Texas is a great place for it too
because Texas,
there's a lot of mushrooms that grow
wild out there.
Yeah.
W Yeah,
we,
um,
we kind of have parties where we would
run around and go pick them and yeah.
Did you really?
Yeah.
It's kind of gross.
Pick them off couch.
Yeah.
It's disgusting.
But how did you know they were the right
ones?
Oh,
uh,
I is the group of people.
Well,
I surrounding myself,
ah,
people that my mom said you should stay
away from them.
Those mycologists.
Yeah.
Um,
so it was just kinda like,
uh,
I was hanging with the right crowd.
Right crowd.
The right crowd.
Yeah.
It definitely,
it turns out to be the right crowd,
right.
The right crowd.
You know,
the ones that your mom probably told you
should hang out with,
they're on fucking antidepressants right
now.
Freaking out,
hitting Midlife,
wondering what the fuck they're doing
with themselves.
Having children being,
being trapped in some job where there,
you know,
most likely with the people that go the
way that everybody wanted us to go.
Like whether it's a lawyer or successful
businessman,
they're stressed the fuck out working
long crazy hours.
Right?
Yeah.
I totally agree.
I mean,
I feel like regardless of,
or despite the,
uh,
the tension that I had,
I mean,
I grew up constantly very strict,
very,
um,
you know,
I was raised baptist,
very straight,
very strict family,
military.
So any of that was completely taboo and
I would,
that would be my ass if they found out
anything about it.
But for some reason I felt like I wanted
to break out and,
and discover on my own,
you know what I mean?
And not kind of not be locked into what
was just laid out for me,
you know?
Yeah.
And,
um,
so yeah,
you're right.
It turned out being the right crowd,
not doing great.
That's just seems to be a common theme.
Suppression leads to,
you know,
trying to alleviate that suppression by
this not listening well by you just
going crazy by your exploring,
taking chances.
Oftentimes like the most strict
upbringings,
but deliver a child is like more prone
to rebellion and I just,
kids don't like to be told what the fuck
to do.
Yeah.
You're there.
It's normal.
Tell me what to do exactly what I'm zack
opposite.
Yeah.
And I'm sure you're probably going to
impart that into your own children too,
because you kind of remember,
I mean,
I certainly do with my children.
I remember being told what to do and
just you strapped me fucking crazy.
People don't like it.
They,
they,
they don't mind rules.
If the rules make sense.
Like,
Hey,
don't stick a fork into electric socket
cause he could fucking die.
Oh,
okay.
That's a big one at my house right now.
How old your kid just turned one.
Oh yeah.
Figured out how to open the door and
walk like it within two days.
Boy.
Girl,
boy.
Yeah,
they're mobile man.
It was like,
yeah,
Jesus.
Yeah.
He started checking pumps.
They wake up,
they don't say Shit and you might be
sleeping and then like,
let me just fucking check out what's
going on in this house.
What is that Chord puck stuck in the
wall.
Hmm.
There's some holes in there,
you know,
some other shit would fit in there like
coins and then they start sticking
things in there.
Blowing my mind right now anyway.
Yeah,
they're,
they're uh,
they're fascinating.
They're little people.
You know,
but yeah,
I'm trying to,
you know,
definitely be conscious of,
of,
of that,
you know,
as,
as he grows and,
and,
and uh,
I wouldn't mind questioning why.
Yeah.
There's the whole,
because,
right.
Because I said,
Eh,
yeah,
yeah.
I can't,
can't do that.
Yeah.
I can't do that to this.
It drives me fucking nuts.
Of course.
Well,
I have a theory on all that stuff.
I think that every generation gathers up
the information of how the previous
generation fucked up.
And as long as there's no cataclysmic
disasters and we're not living in Mad
Max Times where it's like desperado days
and everyone's fending for themselves
and it's just about survival,
then things just keep getting better.
Right.
Well now you can pull out your mobile
though,
vice and you know,
figure out what's really happening,
you know?
Yeah.
And,
and uh,
that's kind of a trip.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
to kind of grow up in and just not
really,
no,
not have access.
Like we have access now.
I mean,
it still blows my mind like that.
I forget sometimes that if I want to
know something I can just google.
Yeah,
instant.
I mean it's,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
So I saw something you were talking
about these google glasses and like,
you know,
these whole being,
these,
I don't know what it is,
it's a my buddy Chris was trying to tell
me about it as well.
Well there's a bunch of different kinds.
There's the regular google glasses,
which a lot of people have,
which is a very small
lens.
It sits on like a mock frames.
It looks like a glass frame without any
glasses in it.
And then there's one small window but
that didn't really catch on.
So what they're working on now is a
contact lenses that do the same thing.
And,
but the Google,
the glass thing,
you had like a little swipe thing and
you could like swipe left and right and
move it around.
Like so he could go,
like I could say,
I could Google Gary Clark images and I
would see in that little tiny window
images of you and I could just swipe
through them.
You could say navigate to the Hollywood
bowl.
And it would take,
it would show you google maps,
how to get to the Hollywood bowl and he
would talk to you in your ear.
But people didn't like it cause it
looked goofy and,
and when people were wearing them,
other people got pissed off.
Like are you filming me?
Like what are you doing?
Cause you could fill them with them too.
So now they're,
they've moved to contact lenses,
which they haven't really released yet
but they're working on them.
And then there's another one that's way
crazier,
which is like goggles and these are like
ski goggles and when you put these
motherfuckers on,
you're going to be able to play video
games in three d space.
You're going to have like three
dimensional holograms around you.
That's the thing.
That's the thing I was wondering about.
So called magic leap or now magically
visit one magic leap in the Hollow Lens
by Microsoft.
That's the one with the goggles,
right?
The Hollow Lens.
But yeah.
What are you thinking about that?
It's crazy.
This is just step one.
I've actually been talking about this
onstage recently because I'm actually
kind of freaked out about it,
that we're going to enter a world within
the next hundred years where artificial
reality is indistinguishable from
regular reality.
It's the matrix.
It's 100% going to happen if we don't
blow ourselves up and we don't die from
disease.
If we don't get hit by an asteroid,
we're going to be able to figure out a
way to trick the mind into thinking.
It's experiencing things that it's not
experiencing.
Whether how long it takes is just
subjective,
but whatever the amount of time it is in
the history of the universe or the
history of this planet,
it's a blink and in one blank,
you're not going to be able to tell
where the reality is real or not.
You're going to be able to plug into
something and you're going to be able to
have artificial experiences.
So like we could do this like,
hey,
yeah,
we might be doing it right now.
That's what's fucked up about it.
When,
when scientists study artificial reality
and they study what they call computer
simulation theory,
they're the real mind fuck is.
It's hard to tell whether or not this is
a simulation and that it's very likely
that it could be that our entire
universe could be some sort of a massive
simulation that we're experiencing and
might not even be like a computer
simulation.
It might be some sort of a simulation
that's going on,
like at a cellular level,
like some sort of a mass hallucination.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's emily isn't enough.
It was not my theories,
but I think about that.
These are not my ideas.
Oh yeah.
I don't even know what to say about
that.
Think about what you said right about
Google Ryan,
about being able to go to your phone and
have it all the answers when you were a
kid.
That was magic.
That was magic,
right?
The idea behind that was insane.
Just 20 years ago,
1996 the idea of being able to do that
was insane.
Everybody be like,
what in the fuck are you talking about?
You're going to be to reach a new phone.
You've gotta be able to touch a piece of
glass.
You can not,
you didn't have to touch it.
You press a button and you talk to it
and it'll tell you anything you need to
know.
Like what?
How the fuck is that possible?
You're going to go watch videos on it.
Shut the fuck up.
You're going to watch movies on it.
You're gonna be able to play hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of hours of
music on it.
It'll sound beautiful and it all be a
thing that's so slim and sleek.
It fits right in your pocket.
Like we're already living in some crazy
movie that they didn't even predict.
And Star track a sidetrack.
They had walkie talkies number.
That's crazy.
It is crazy.
I'm just getting old.
What does this Jamie,
Microsoft added a new update to what
hollow lens is going to look like.
This is what they think is watching.
Sports will be like in the future kind
of says like what?
Watching football.
A football game,
right?
Oh you be able to watch it in front of
you.
All sorts of players.
You can have players in stats pop up and
you're like living room and get extra.
It looks really,
so everyone's just going to sit down and
put these goggles on instead of having a
television or with the television.
So you'll have access to TV.
Look at this.
I could only imagine what like a UFC
event watching that would be like,
you know what I mean?
To get extra stats on the players will
be really cool.
Also,
probably we'll put a big camera on the
referee so you'd be inside of it are
watching me watching from their view,
you know what I mean?
Watching from any players view if you
choose to,
if they can pull that off with,
well they probably could do that with
players.
It wouldn't be able to do it with
fighters.
But with the pride,
they used to have a camera,
but they would put on the referees.
It was this crazy dorky thing.
It was like real big and clunky.
It was like a camera that's sat next to
their head and they would,
uh,
they would wear that thing and it was
kind of cool to see it from their
perspective,
but that was fairly rudimentary
considering it was like early two
thousands,
like what this is going to be is going
to be bananas,
but then you got to hang out with
goggles on,
you know,
friends have to have goggles.
Oh Man.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I guess it's,
it's kind of like the silent disco
thing.
What's the silent disco thing?
A silent disco is like where people,
like a whole bunch of people hang out in
a room or a club and they have
headphones on and there's like,
there's Djs and you can decide if you
want to go with Dj,
a Dj be.
And so it was a bunch of people like
dancing in a silent room with headphones
on.
Really like having a great time.
And then it's like,
do you want to drink?
What?
Oh,
is this it right here?
You show me this Jamie.
So this is people the dancing around and
they just have different wireless
headsets on.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Oh this is crazy.
Okay.
Everyone's just listening to the same
thing.
There's just no out like no one outside
can hear you.
Well that's good to your neighbors.
That's awesome.
In that way it's great for your
neighbors.
Yeah.
You don't have to be rude because it's
like that one asshole on your block who
has a party but his music tastes sox.
There was this part of that they had
near my neighborhood about 10 years ago
and it was the most fucking depressing,
like trapped in the,
it was like,
Oh let me try to remember what kind of
music there.
But it was like the captain and to kneel
or some shit.
It was so bad.
It was just like,
like how would they cranking this?
Like what the fuck are they doing?
You want to show up at their house with
like some wine?
That's a bad example.
I can't remember what it was cause I
blocked it out.
Like childhood molestation.
It was so bad.
They were,
they were playing this fucking terrible,
but it was like this asshole was playing
it loud like he,
it wasn't,
you couldn't even enjoy,
it was so loud.
There's no way he was enjoying it.
He was enjoying showing off that he was
having a party with this shitty music
that him and his dying friends were
playing.
What do you listen to?
I listened to a lot of classic rock a
lot.
Like as I get older it just seems like
I'm becoming that old dude that listens
to classic rock.
Like I listen to a lot of Leonard
Skinner,
a lot of Hendrix.
I've been listening to a lot of,
um,
boy,
just almost anything from the 60s and
the early seventies is what a lot of,
a lot of what I listened to.
Listen,
a lot of credence lately.
Craziness.
Yeah,
that's good.
I uh,
fuck with his voice used to kind of mess
me up,
but I've come to like,
except appreciate the tone and like the,
you know,
comes from a heartfelt place.
When I was younger I couldn't,
what's he saying?
Yeah,
you got to,
there's certain music that you got to
revisit as you hit different stages in
life.
I think there's certain music that I
wasn't into and then I'll go back now
and now I can get into it.
Credence is one of those.
Yeah.
Like my friends in high school or in the
credence and no one was
yeah.
In high school people were listening to.
Hm.
Uh,
the Houston like Swisher House,
Paul Wall.
Um,
that's all it.
Cough Syrup.
Music,
right?
Yeah.
It's like,
so it was a dat ugk outcast lot of Dave
Matthews.
Okay.
A lot.
Dave Matthews I went to,
I went to like this,
I went to the school board.
Dangerous shut this podcast off.
Right.
That's it.
That's done there.
But it was different.
Cory,
moral Robert or
gain like a lot of it was different.
Like,
um,
and some of it I've come to appreciate
and some of it I've just kinda left
behind.
I like outcast,
outcast.
They do a lot of experimental shit.
Yeah,
they're great.
They do a lot of interest.
It didn't,
didn't want to do from outkast.
Was any supposed to play Jimmy Hendrix?
He did.
Yeah,
he did that movie.
I never heard of it.
No,
never,
never heard a thing about it.
They just came and went.
Did you see it?
Yeah,
I saw it out here.
How was it?
Uh,
it was good as far as the story.
I mean it was,
I felt like I,
uh,
Andre Played Hendrix.
Great.
Uh,
there was a lot of the stuff that I
didn't know that where they had to do
different music cause they couldn't use
the Hendrix music.
So that,
that for me was kind of fucked me up a
little bit,
a little bit because it was,
it was recreated and then being a guitar
player
was it quiet?
Like it really Kinda mess me up.
But I mean the story was,
was great and I think Andre did a great
job in the casita great job considering
what they,
you know,
we're working with,
but there was no Hendrickson music.
How could they should scrap the project
or paid up,
paid the family.
You got to pay the family if you want to
make a fucking documentary or a bio pic.
About arguably the greatest guitarist
that's ever lived.
You gotta use this fucking music and got
to give his parents the money or
whoever,
whoever's alive,
give him the money and if you gotta pay
him,
that's the only way you're going to do
it.
Right.
Otherwise you're going to get a movie
like that where we don't talk about it
just goes in and out.
Yeah.
The guitar thing must drive you crazy
though when you know he's not really
playing that I couldn't handle it
cause me on a much lesser scale.
I'm not a professional pool player,
but when I watched someone in a movie
and I know they can't really play pool,
it's very obvious.
You see the way a guy's holding a stick,
the way the stick moves in their arm.
It's like,
have you ever seen someone hold a
cigarette that doesn't really smoke and
you could tell like a smoker can tell
like almost immediately when someone
doesn't actually smoke or at least
someone who is not aware of how people
smoke smoke.
I'm sure an actor can figure out how to
smoke like a smoker,
a lot easier than someone could figure
out how to play guitar and Mimic it.
Right.
Because when I see someone who can't
play pool and a movie and you're like,
you know,
pool hall junkies or something like
that,
my shit get that fucking thing off to
tell.
It just drives me crazy.
I that guy can't play,
he can't play.
There's no,
he's doing it all wrong.
I know.
He's really good.
His bridge,
look at the way he's holding it.
This is bullshit.
And that's something real similar.
I mean he real simple
rather,
it's just uh,
the movement of an arm.
And I could tell,
but for fingers and keys and the way a
guy's sounding,
I mean,
they must be bananas to you.
Yeah,
I uh,
yeah,
it drove me nuts.
I mean,
I don't know what to say.
I was like,
fuck,
somebody picks it.
But yeah.
What the fuck man?
How do they not have like a coordinator?
I Dunno.
But you know,
unless your bullshit and unless it's
like a crazy Kung fu movie,
like obviously I have a connection to
martial arts where if I know someone's
doing something that's not really gonna
work,
it'll drive me crazy.
But if he's like,
wow,
like fucking pulling people's hearts out
and flying through the air and throwing
side kicks through buildings,
I'm willing to suspend disbelief,
you know?
But you can't do that for Jimi Hendrix
in a fucking biopic.
Yeah,
that's true.
I've got a question for you.
One of my favorite shows growing up was
Kung Fu with David carradine.
Yeah.
How did you feel about it?
Oh,
bullshit.
Yeah.
I loved it.
It when I was a kid though.
Right.
But you watch it now and you're like,
what?
But it was basically fighting.
People didn't know how to fight.
Think there was no one he fought.
Like some dude came out and was a legit,
and Moy Thai fighters started kicking
his legs.
Right.
The carotene wrote out and killed him.
It was awesome.
Drunk guy with the beer mug.
Yeah,
exactly.
I don't think he really learned Kung Fu
for that show.
I don't know,
but it didn't seem like he did.
It seemed like he had very little,
that seemed like a real martial arts
move.
Yeah.
I don't,
I,
I recently went back a couple of years
ago,
bought the series and watched the whole
thing cause as a kid I loved it.
It was,
yeah,
my dad,
we'll put it on here you go son,
learn something,
you know,
lessons about how not to be an asshole.
Yeah.
And uh,
so yeah,
but I watched it recently and I was
wearing,
I was like,
what are these guys?
So,
you know,
cause he was like,
really know what's up.
How do you feel about this?
Because I don't know.
You know what I mean?
Right.
So yeah,
no one respects it.
Okay.
But it was a good show in terms of
interesting,
like if you take out the martial arts
element of it,
it's an interesting show.
You got this guy who was raised in a,
like a monastery and then he's wandering
to the old west.
It's kind of a cool premise.
The premise behind it is really
interesting,
you know?
And he was like this real calm,
peaceful guy who wasn't an asshole at
all.
I could not have been nicer.
And that was a unique character because
there's really never been anybody on
television.
It was like that.
Just like there's an enlightened,
peaceful guy,
you know,
he had long hair and shit.
He's just kind of a hippie and it's
wandering through life and people keep
fucking with them.
Keep fucking with them.
All right.
You know,
it was interesting in that way.
Like it made a lot of people want to
pretend they're that guy.
I'm sure.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Like house out.
How so?
Yeah.
How are you one of them?
I mean,
uh,
just,
just the attitude,
just the,
you know,
uh,
I would,
I was waiting for a moment,
you know,
I wish somebody would so I could quite
Chang Caine.
That's the opposite though.
He wished somebody would be peaceful.
I mean,
I was a kid so I can all right.
You know,
of course.
I love that.
Speaking of being an inspired man,
you know,
one of my favorite things that I love to
do,
which I haven't done in awhile.
It was,
it was um,
you know,
catch up and watch the UFC,
and get into that.
And um,
I was sitting around and starting to
kind of feel like a piece of shit,
drinking too much and whatever.
And so it was,
you know,
looking at these guys,
training and doing what they do.
So I kinda inspired me to get on my bike
and he'd get the heavy bag and get on
the weights and do my thing.
And uh,
it was really into it.
I haven't been been keeping up for
awhile and kind of got the guts to show
it and I'm working on them.
I need to get back on my game is what
I'm saying.
Do you want to train while you were in
la?
Is that what you're saying?
I would love to find you need to,
I need to do.
So we'll talk off the air and uh,
I'll,
I'll get you to know like are you
interested in taking Jujitsu or what are
you interested in doing?
Well,
whatever it was was kind of right for,
for me and my build and,
well I don't have a whole lot of time
but I'm definitely interested in and
getting back into it and get my mind
focused.
The real reality is there's different
styles of Jujitsu that are great for
every build.
And when I say different styles,
I mean different approaches to Jujitsu
is so broad.
There's so many different techniques and
there's so many different strategies and
so many different moves and countermoves
that your build is perfect for Jujitsu.
You along and tall,
you have long arms and long legs and you
can catch people in chokes that a stubby
little dude like me can't cause I have
short arms,
short legs,
you know,
it's different,
but different builds like mine are
better for certain positions like this,
this guy who some are Paul Harris who's,
he's like me but more exaggerated.
He's way thicker and more muscular and
he just tears people's legs apart.
He's a leg lock specialist and there's a
lot of other guys that are smaller that
is like really fast and they're good at
taking people's backs like Marcella
Garcia.
But um,
there's a lot of tall guys and Jujitsu.
It's,
there's definitely an advantage.
It's an advantage of leverage.
I'm like just mechanical leverage from
having long limbs.
It's good for striking to them,
man.
It's good for learning,
not striking arts.
Like if I,
if I had to say like,
if there's one bill that has like the
most definitive advantages,
I would say tall and long because it's
harder to hit you because you're further
away from me.
Uh,
you get hit me in a place where I can
hit you.
Like how tall are you?
Six,
four,
six,
four.
I'm five.
Eight.
So you're dealing with all that.
You're dealing with eight extra inches.
So eight extra inches between,
uh,
your head in my head,
which may or may not translate as far as
like,
uh,
how long your arms are,
how long your legs are.
But definitely there's a at least a few
inches of advantage,
which means like if we're both throwing
punches at the same time,
you had hit me before I would hit you
and I probably would never hit you
because of that because he would hit me
like as I was throwing up punch and I'd
get fucked up like that.
That's a big advantage.
Like John Jones,
the UFC,
a former light heavyweight champion.
He's like the best at you cause he's a
big tall dude and he's the best at like
using that advantage.
It's one of the best advantages of being
long and tall.
Right?
Yeah.
I'm ready.
You Ready?
I need to do checking,
moving your jacket.
I was like balling up my fists way.
You're talking to like,
yes,
do this.
Well that's a great way to blow off
energy and stress.
I need that as well.
Definitely people get addicted to it.
Like we was talking about bordain um,
he didn't even start doing it until he
was 58 and 57 58 and now he does it
every day.
He does Jiu Jitsu every day.
He loves it.
He's obsessed with it.
Yeah.
A lot of musicians get into it.
Um,
I know a lot of musicians that are in a
Jiu Jitsu,
they,
because it becomes like a martial arts
really are an art form.
It doesn't seem an art form to the
outsider because people,
they say,
oh,
it's just fighting.
It's just brutality.
But the reality is there's way,
way,
way more people who are into martial
arts who never get into a fight ever
then,
then people who use it either in
competition or use it for self defense.
It's uh,
it's,
it's a form of art.
It's an expression.
And you,
when you watch someone pull off a move,
it's beautiful.
It's just,
it's one of those things that seems to
be only beautiful for people who
understand it,
but for people to understand that it's
amazing.
Yeah.
No,
I mean,
I can respect it.
I,
I kind of understand what's going on.
I can appreciate it.
Like,
you know,
someone playing a nice solo or something
and executing it well yeah,
I can kind of get that,
you know,
the,
the art,
the what it takes to pay attention to
and be in that moment and,
and you know,
uh,
execute.
It's a bunch.
It's that,
it's a bunch of other factors too.
It's setting up an attack that either
the person couldn't anticipate or
couldn't figure out what to do in time
and then it locks in and then once it
locks in and be like,
Oh shit,
it's beautiful.
It's like,
it's like a painting or a work of art or
masterful guitar solo or any of those
things.
Art Is your,
your dedication and your focus and then
the expression and the results of that
dedication and focus in a way where like
if I'll watch someone pull off a move
that I don't know how to do,
it's particularly beautiful to me
because I'm like,
Oh shit,
look what he did that like there's
certain moves that I'll have to replay
like over and over and over again.
Like,
I'll watch certain setups like over and
over and over again until I get it into
my head and,
and I didn't this so many different ways
to move the body that there's a lot of
like I've been doing Jujitsu since 1996
and there's still a bunch of moves that
I don't know,
I don't understand and I have to go,
oh,
how did he do that?
How did he do that?
But today,
like we're talking about like with
Google,
we're so lucky that we could just go to
youtube videos.
And one of the beautiful things about
Jujitsu is it used to be that martial
arts where like a secret,
this is the secret death touch.
And nobody would tell you that secret
death touch,
right?
It didn't exist.
It was bullshit.
The reality of Jujitsu is almost every
move people are dying to explain to
people because people love learning new
shit.
People that are Jujitsu artists love
learning new stuff.
So people that are Jujutsu artists that
have a new move,
love to put that move online.
It's a big part of the community.
A huge part of the community is sharing
and openness.
So like everybody does seminars and
everybody teaches everybody everything.
But in the early days it wasn't like
that.
Even the early days of Jujitsu when what
happened was in 1993 when the UFC was
created,
people first started to see Jujitsu and
they were like,
what the fuck?
But there was a lot of moves like
triangles or things like along those
lines where I had friends that would
take classes at certain schools and they
would say,
hey,
you know,
hoists gracie tapped out Dan Saffron
with a triangle,
how do I do that?
And the teacher like,
you're not ready for that yet.
Like I can't teach you that yet,
but that's,
that's a black belt technique or that's
a purple belt technique or whatever.
And they just,
and people are turned off to it.
And then they found other more
unconventional openminded schools that
immediately taught everybody everything.
And those are the schools that became
prosperous.
Those schools were really successful.
And the schools that held people back,
they never produce champions,
they never produced any like real
notable Jujitsu players.
And the open minded like experimental
schools,
those are the ones that blew up.
It's really interesting in that way,
like the free exchange of information
overwhelmingly won out in the world of
Jujitsu.
That makes sense to me.
It does,
right?
Yeah.
So how does it like,
um,
like I,
I have a same kind of appreciation for
like,
like the art,
martial arts,
comedy,
music,
um,
you know,
anything like that.
Like,
I can appreciate the hard work and
everything that goes back into,
so you feel the same way about martial
arts is like comedy or do you approach
it the same way or?
Well,
um,
in some ways,
yeah,
in some ways it's,
it's about practice,
dedication,
application and reality.
Like if something's not funny,
it's just not funny.
If people don't laugh,
they just don't laugh.
And if a technique doesn't work,
it just doesn't work.
You know,
if you can't pull it off,
if somebody chokes you,
they just choked you.
You know,
you could be a 20 year black belt,
right.
And some dude catches you in a
guillotine.
He's only been doing Jujitsu for six
months,
but someone teaches him how to do this.
Grab your arm like that.
Polar,
any someone's neck,
wrap your legs around him at squeeze and
you can't get out.
Well,
he tapped you.
Even if he's only been doing Jujitsu for
six months and you've been doing Jujitsu
for 30 years,
it's stays.
It's still real for guy taps you,
they tap you just,
there's no,
if it's like,
it's one of the things I love about
pool.
The ball either goes in the hole or it
doesn't go in the hole.
It doesn't matter if either knock it in
the hole or you don't.
There's no almost made that shot.
That doesn't mean Jack Shit,
you know,
it doesn't mean anything.
I'm that asshole who says that.
Well,
we all say it,
but you know the reality of the actual
winning of the game,
right?
It's a personality thing.
Like,
sometimes people can get really far on a
bullshit personality and a lot of
bravado and a lot of bragging and a lot
of false stories and,
and,
and then the actual application life is,
they've sort of skirted through with all
the dance moves and all the personality,
but they don't have any real substance
to it.
That doesn't work in Jujitsu.
Just like,
it doesn't really work in comedy,
comedy,
like personality accounts for certain
amount of the audience accepting you.
But ultimately if the concepts aren't
there and if you don't have like a good
setup,
if you don't know how to deliver it in a
way that people are gonna,
like it's going to easily enter into
their mind and they're going to like
carry along,
then it either works or it doesn't.
And there's,
there's,
there's some parallel truths in that in
martial arts and in comedy in that way.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm very intrigued by all of it,
so that's why I'm asking some very
curious.
I want to get in there.
Well,
all complex systems,
whether it's music or writing,
I'm creating a movie.
Anything complex things are fascinating
to me too cause I just like,
I've never made a movie,
but I want to see like CGI animators.
I go watch this.
Uh,
this um,
documentary on a guy's making a animated
scenes for films like special effects
scenes.
And I think to myself,
wow,
that is fascinating that they're
creating an artificial world and inside
that artificial world,
they have these creatures moving and
they have these people they'd have to
put on these motion capture suits and go
through the motions,
pretending they're interacting with
these things that aren't even there.
And then someone has to peace.
It's amazing to me.
It's amazing to me,
but I'm not going to do it.
I don't have any time.
But I look at that the same way I kind
of look at music or the same way I look
at writing or comedy or anything.
So it's fascinating to me watching
someone go after something and put it
together and make something that is
almost unfathomable take place.
Whether it's a creation of an album,
whether it's a,
you know,
a comedy special,
whether it's someone writes an amazing
book.
I love when people get shit done.
Yeah,
I do too.
It's a beautiful thing.
Yeah.
Right.
Well as artists,
right?
Like,
does that,
like,
as as an artist,
does that inspire you when you see,
like if you go to see a great movie or
read a great book or something like
that,
does that inspire you to want to
create?
Yeah.
It doesn't inspire me to create a write
a book.
Right,
right,
right.
But,
um,
I think I kind of know what my lane is
right.
This point.
Yeah.
I try and stay in it.
Um,
but yeah,
I mean,
I definitely go see you,
uh,
a movie or,
or,
or read,
uh,
you know,
and,
and it,
it'll get my creative juices flowing
and,
you know,
inspired me to be just be better and try
and contribute,
you know what I mean?
Contributes something good or be
positive and make,
make myself feel something to make
somebody else feel something.
I Dunno.
It,
it does something to me.
Definitely.
It's hard to describe.
I was still can't describe what it is
that makes this creative thing,
um,
click or explain how I do what I do.
But you definitely see in movies or
hearing,
you know,
here and um,
like great musicians,
great guitar players,
you know,
the freak me out.
Oh Shit,
don't get too involved a little bit,
you know what I mean?
And I'm like,
just hold the hunger,
but yeah,
no,
it's like,
okay,
I respect that.
Let me go get on my game and do my
thing.
There was this,
uh,
ah,
man,
there was this a guitar player,
um,
down in Austin,
Texas who I haven't seen in awhile.
And uh,
his name is Derek O'brian is one of the
greatest blues guitar players in the
world.
Played backed up muddy waters.
Um,
Albert Collins,
Albert can't,
everybody's like in the house band at
Anton says this club.
Um,
I hadn't seen him in awhile.
And so I go back home and I got my
little reputation and you know,
people are like,
ah,
you know this by that,
that,
you know,
I'm like,
all right,
I know my strengths and weaknesses,
but I was feeling good about myself and
then I got up on stage and let this,
you know,
this guy was just ripping it and I just,
in that moment I was like,
I ain't got shit on this guy.
You know what that's like.
It was,
it was a nice reality check.
So I immediately went back and started
shedding and I've been kind of doing it
since.
Yeah,
that's a beautiful thing about being
around inspiring artists.
It's one of the cool things about being
in a place like an la or Nashville or if
you're a musician,
if that's your style,
I'm music or Austin or anywhere where
there's a good group of people that are
also doing the same thing.
So you use those people and they use you
and everybody's like fuel for each
other.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
That's,
um,
I'm starting to kind of figure out the
scenes here and in La a little bit more
as well.
You know,
I went out the other night and had like
this sitting in a jazz musicians and you
know,
really like the best of the best people
are on top of their game.
Folks who can read charts.
Yeah.
When you do you practice,
like do you go to like are there certain
clubs that I'm a musician,
like you can go and just fuck around
with new stuff.
Like for standups,
we'll go to the comedy store and we'll
practice or we'll go to the Improv and
we'll practice.
Like if I have some new bits and I'm
working on right,
I will go there and I'll air them out.
Right.
Um,
yeah.
In,
in Austin,
well,
from,
there's this spa,
every Sunday I'll have a blues jam,
you know?
And uh,
so yeah.
Yeah.
You would either go sit in with people
that you don't know I haven't played
with before or whatever and,
you know,
try out some new chords.
Maybe you learned something fancy that
could,
you know,
transition chord,
to go from the one to five on a
turnaround in this little blue is
whatever,
and the key to see whatever,
you know.
So you'd go work that out and um,
or you bring your squad.
I mean,
me and my buddies,
a potter when he plays in my band,
we would go up sometimes and no,
a drummer that kind of knew how we
floated and the Bass player who could
pick up on something like,
and we got this new track,
we're about to fuck people up.
This either would work or it wasn't.
But yeah,
those places.
And um,
yeah,
that's the kind of the fuel,
you know,
to be in those spots and be around other
players and get up and do that thing.
Um,
yeah,
that's,
it was nothing like that.
Yeah.
So for you,
when you create music,
is it,
um,
like do you just get an idea,
like how did,
what does the creation process from,
is it,
does it vary or is there a specific
creation process from the moment you get
an idea to putting it to paper or to
remembering it and making a song and
putting the beat to it and pin it,
putting the sounds to it?
Um,
it's kind of an unorganized mess.
I said I haven't figured out a process
and um,
I don't think it's a mess.
I think it just comes naturally.
Like I'll have a guitar and I might,
you know,
have a chord progression and it'll just
kind of stick and then I'll put a melody
over it.
I'll be singing something around the
house and grabbed the guitar and put
that together.
Or um,
you know,
technology.
I love being able to travel and you
know,
I travel a lot,
so on airplane or on the bus I'll pull
out the NPC or something and kind of put
in drum tracks and build from there,
whatever.
So it all just kind of depends on where
I am.
And what I have access to and um,
uh,
but now having a little one being at
home,
I was like,
gotta like take advantage of my time.
It's like all you have an hour here,
go try and make something happen.
Right.
So it's ever,
ever changing it,
but it just,
whatever feels right.
You know,
I don't think if,
if it becomes too much of a formula,
then I think it will lose its,
uh,
it's
raw,
organic
kind of
what I got into it for,
which is kind of not knowing and not not
having any rules.
Uh,
you know,
so yeah,
it,
it just
pins.
That's a real common thing that you said
that a lot of people say that once they
had a kid,
they realized that their free time is
actually precious.
So because kids demands so much time,
babies demands so much time and you just
really don't have much to,
you start going,
okay,
the kid's asleep.
Let's get to work,
you know,
and you actually get more done because
you have children than you did when you
were free.
Oh Man.
I would sit around and eat us single
living by myself,
be working on the software,
eight hours,
I'd have it loop playing,
you know,
and just,
uh,
let me go get some food.
I'll come back to that and maybe some
awesome.
Maybe I'll get like the genius idea or
whatever.
And um,
yeah,
I spent two months working on one song
and you know,
I don't,
you don't have that much time anymore,
so it's blessing,
you know,
kind of like get your shit together,
you're going to do it or you're not.
Yeah.
Louis C ck was the first person to tell
me that and it didn't,
it was so counter intuitive.
I was like,
really?
He's like,
yeah,
I actually,
I get a lot more done now that I have
children than I did when I was free to
do whatever I wanted.
He was like,
now I'm just under the gun all the time.
So that's how I get things done.
Yeah.
Well creatively,
I guess for me,
I mean we spend so much time out on the
road,
like we're gone a lot,
so it's a kind of need,
my quiet time.
And there's not really a lot of quiet
time with a bunch of dudes hanging
around,
smelled like ass.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
It's just,
it's,
it's a lot and I can't really function
that way,
so I kind of have to be home in order to
be creative and do that.
When you go on the road,
do you do like long stretches like you
on the road for like two months at a
time and have a bunch of dates laid out
for you?
Yeah,
we,
I mean,
we take off here next week and we're
pretty much gone,
um,
until
maybe August or something.
Whoa.
I mean,
we will have a few days here and there.
I'll come back home and uh,
you know,
we'll be in when you bring your family.
Yeah.
They'll come with me sometimes and um,
yeah,
like we just,
they just came with us.
We were in Australia and you know,
just did the whole trip,
you know,
on the planes,
everything.
Woo.
That flight.
Yeah.
That fight racks you,
it's not my favorite.
It's not my favorite either.
I kind of hate it.
Yeah.
Somebody just offered me a trip to New
Zealand,
a vacation trip to New Zealand.
I was like,
bitch,
that's not a vacation work.
16 hours of the fucking plane or
whatever the hell it is.
Like,
come on.
It doesn't,
there's nothing vacation.
He about that,
Eh,
I,
it's beautiful over there,
you know?
But by the time he can get over that
you're tired,
you just want to go back home.
I would think that it would be a
vacation for someone who didn't travel
all the time.
But for someone like you or someone like
me who's always traveling,
it's like,
what?
Yeah.
I kinda like to be at home.
Kind of boring that way.
It's like I could be at my house for
like three days straight.
Yeah.
But that's also because you travel so
much.
It's in direct contrast to that.
So it's a welcome change.
Right.
But I got guys on my crew who get right
off tour and just go hit it.
Yeah.
Single guys though.
No.
Really?
Yeah.
Like,
get off the plane,
uh,
you know,
from the tour.
And then just like boss up,
my boy went to Cuba.
Well,
like going on tour for,
for it seemed like what forever.
And then he's like chilling and Cuba,
but like why?
And that seems exhausting.
But Cuba is one of those places though.
I think I need to go to,
I think I need to go do it before it
changes.
It's,
yeah.
So soon.
Yeah.
Cause right now there's no internet.
They don't have any internet.
Right.
You can't keep track your emails.
There's like a couple spots we need to
get like three g my boy Chris Christian
and found them.
Yeah.
How he found them.
He found them.
He was like,
I love it.
What's up Chris?
He goes,
he goes,
I'm going down to queue.
I'm not going to be able to,
I'm not going to be able to uh,
get in touch with you.
Um,
and I was like,
all right man,
you know,
I get it.
Cool,
have fun.
And then I get this call from this weird
number.
He's like,
Yo,
he fell in the one spot and I was like,
man,
why don't you just enjoy,
you know,
chill out.
Just be off the for a minute.
Yeah.
Sorry.
It's one of the things I like most about
a hunting trips.
Like a lot of them,
you're in places where you don't have a
choice.
You're in the middle of a mountain.
Nothing up here,
dude.
Nothing.
You might be able to get to the top of a
mountain,
send someone a text message.
They might not be able to reply and they
might not even get it.
I might just get lost in the air
somewhere.
That's kind of where I need to go to the
go.
I'm write my songs,
get out.
So hunting trips,
dude,
I saw this thing.
You,
it's like this big ass all.
Is it like a moose?
Oh,
Moose leg.
Yeah.
It's like walking through that airport,
walking through somewhere and I was
like,
what the fuck?
I felt
like this small of a,
like a man.
I was like,
dude,
this guy is beast mode.
Right?
Well,
um,
that was,
uh,
intentionally they wanted to make
something that was like as in your face
about the realities of meat as possible.
Right.
You know,
I got into it with some people on
twitter the other day cause I like,
I like to troll vegans occasionally.
I see you cause someone was making,
there were some making some stupid shit
saying that saturated fats are terrible
for you.
Like they're the another not,
they're not there.
Scientific studies that show saturated
fats are actually healthy for you and
important for you.
But people think that if you hunt or if
you're involved somehow in animals that
year sometime sometimes eating animals
that you're a cruel person,
that you,
you want to hurt animals.
You want to cause pain and suffering.
The,
no,
I don't,
I don't want to have anything to do with
factory farming because I don't want to
be involved in that.
But the animals that I'm out hunting,
like if I don't get them a wolf's get
them or a coyote getting him or her
mountain lions getting,
I'm like,
they're not living forever.
They have a very short window of time.
Whether they're alive,
they're,
if they're,
if they make it,
if a deere makes it a six years old that
is a really old deer and most of them
they die.
Long before that when I'm doing is I'm
stumped dipping my feet into that wild
world and I'm pulling something out of
it and that's where I get all my protein
from or all my animal protein.
I don't,
I love animals.
I think they're amazing.
I have cats at home.
I have dogs.
It's not a cruelty to animals thing and
this is something that I used to think
of when I thought of hunters.
Like I saw some telephone shores.
Hunter had a dog and he's petting his
dog.
I was like,
how's this motherfucker differentiate
between this dog and some deer?
He's gonna like,
shoot,
it's the lungs out.
Like how that's Kinda fucked up.
It's kind of weird.
But then I got it.
Like the dog is a killer too,
man.
Everything life eats life and it's not a
matter of being cruel.
It's a matter of sustainability and
being alive.
Then there's the reality of hunting.
Then not everybody can hunt.
Not Everybody has the time.
Not everybody wants to,
especially in the world that we're,
we've grown up in with the cities and
it's something that took me several
years to sort of get into it and really
understand what it's all about and
educate myself.
And then once I did educate myself,
one of the most compelling things was
how ignorant most people are about the
facts of hunting,
about the facts of wildlife,
about wildlife management,
and about just where their food comes
from.
And even about how many animals die
making grain.
How many of my people say,
you know,
I only eat,
I only keen and fucking Alfalfa and
guess what?
That shit's getting chopped up in a
combine.
And it's chewing up bunnies and fawns
and rats and mice and sparrows and
ground nesting birds and,
and you're removing the habitat when you
growing food like that for a lot of
different wildlife,
wildlife gets displaced and the
displaced wildlife wind getting preyed
on this.
It's like there's a lot of factors
involved in gathering food and when
we're living in cities,
we're living in this bizarre natural
environment.
And when I say cities are a natural
environment,
they are a natural environment because
they're there.
They're everywhere.
They're a natural environment for
people.
Like anybody says the cities aren't
natural man.
Well,
how come there's so many of them?
Like what is nature?
What does a beehive,
is it a beehive nature?
A beehive is nature,
right?
Well,
that's a fucking be city.
Okay?
They've created a city.
They know how to do it.
They do it everywhere.
That's the same goddamn thing people do.
We create these super complicated
beehives are call them cities and we
create them all over the world,
right?
It's not like this one city.
And we're like,
what the fuck is that?
The cities are everywhere.
They are people.
And when people figure shit out and they
have electricity and they have
agriculture,
then they have surplus and then they,
they put up fucking walls and make
buildings and then boom,
we got a city and they're everywhere.
You look,
I think,
I think there's,
there's just some strange detachment
from where our food comes from when it's
shipped in and trucks all the time.
So my,
uh,
education into the world of hunting,
a big part of it was like to try to
figure out,
like,
I try to figure out bizarre things,
like things that don't make sense to me.
I try to figure out,
I tried to figure out,
uh,
all sorts of weird misconceptions and
misunderstandings.
I this what fascinates me about people
that are involved in cults.
So it fascinates me,
but people that have bad conceptions or
bad thoughts about psychedelics that are
untrue,
like people would think that,
you know,
certain things or make it to make you go
crazy and lose your mind.
What,
well,
why is that?
What makes people,
oh,
well there's propaganda films for the
1930s.
Well,
what started that while it was a guy
named William Randolph hearst,
I'll actually profited from marijuana
being illegal.
Like,
oh,
okay.
And he get,
I'm fascinated by shit like that.
So the food thing was always fascinating
to me.
Like how was actually just go to a store
and you get a piece of meat and we have
no idea where the fuck this meat came
from.
We'd literally just,
we don't even care.
We throw it in the supermarket,
you know,
throw it in the cart,
go through supermarket,
give that guy a piece of plastic.
He runs it through the machine and
you're out the door.
It's strange.
It's very odd when that's a piece of
life.
Yeah,
I think about that too,
but I don't hunt,
but do you eat me?
I do,
but it's not guilty.
It's normal.
Deep meet everybody like 90% this is the
fact of the world eats meat.
He right 90 95 depending on who you ask,
but it's at least 90 of the world eats
meat.
Even Vegetarians,
most vegetarian,
some asshole said to me the other day,
hilarious.
He goes,
I'm 90% vegetarian and I think,
oh,
shut the fuck up.
Does you can't say that?
How do you do that with how?
That's not 90% vegetarian.
That's not real.
There's no such thing as 90% vegetarian.
You are 100% not vegetarian.
If you eat meat,
that's not 90% vegetarian.
He's an asshole.
He's a convenient moral ground asshole
who's just trying to let everybody know
he's better than you because most of the
time he doesn't eat meat.
Just fuck you.
Yeah,
I'll just go ahead and shut the fuck up.
Well,
he was just trying to be,
make an argument against hunting and a
about about people who do it.
You know,
it's just,
he's a fool,
but it's convenient for people because
they're completely detached on,
on a daily basis.
If you go to your office every day,
you wake up in the morning,
you have your breakfast,
you drive to work,
you go to work.
At the end of the day,
you go to the gym,
you go home,
you watch a little television,
you crash,
you get up in the morning,
you do that again and you do it five
days a week.
You're left with two fucking days,
two days,
Saturday and Sunday.
If you're lucky.
And if you have family,
those days are spoken for.
If you have friends,
If you have hobbies,
so where's your gathering food come
from?
Like you,
you have to make a concerted effort.
If you really want to be a part of this,
if you really want to deeply understand
where your food comes from,
you have to make a concerted effort to
either grow it or acquire it.
Like somehow or another you have to go
to a farm and talk to the people that
are growing the food and buy it from
them.
Go to a farmer's market.
You can meet them like,
I go to farmer's markets.
It's kind of cool.
I like meeting the people that work on
the farms.
I asked them to talk to them about it.
But the meat thing is the big
detachment.
Everybody kind of understands.
You plant a seed,
you water it,
tomato comes out,
they kind of get that.
But the animal part,
the vast majority of people who eat meat
just do not understand the whole
process.
They don't,
they don't want to know.
They,
they just buy a burger.
Yeah.
Uh,
I'm starting to know a little bit more
and it freaks me out of it.
It's a freak out,
but you know,
it's a freak out.
I haven't quite switched over to
veganism or going out and hunting.
Yeah,
well,
my thought was I was going to do one or
two things.
I was either going to become a Vegan,
I was going to become a hunter.
And I became a hunter.
And one of the reasons why I became a
hunter is,
first of all,
the food's delicious.
It's good for you.
And those animals aren't,
they're not living forever.
And I becoming fairies and curing
cancer,
if you don't shoot them and they're
getting eaten by all kinds of shit
around them,
you're,
you're just,
you're just eating them as well.
It's,
um,
it's a,
it's a weird disconnect that we have
about where food comes from.
And life itself,
like live is not permanent.
It's temporary.
It's,
it's here and it's gone.
It's fleeting.
It should be respected,
you know,
it should be.
And I think one of the best ways to
respect these animals in the sounds like
total,
totally counter intuitive,
but as to cut them and eat them,
they become a part of your life.
They sustain you.
They,
you know,
you,
you have a deep appreciation for them
because they literally sustain you
there.
Part of what makes you live.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a real,
yeah.
We live in Texas,
a lot of hunting and in Austin
when you were living there.
And a lot of my friends,
you know,
they hunt and so you know that they're
big on it.
Um,
did you ever want to go with them?
I,
I did,
but I had a,
I had a couple of experiences with guns
when I was younger.
That kind of freaked me out from,
from that,
one of them was me being a kid and I was
like a play gun and I kind of colored
the red,
uh,
like kids say she thing,
you know,
I,
me and my buddies,
so he had this like daisy rifle.
I had this little lake,
I don't remember what it was,
but so we'd just like,
we're just messing around,
you know,
actually my kids.
And then this guy comes driving and we,
it's the point that gun at him and this
guy swerved off the road,
hit some mailbox,
like crashes his car.
He gets out,
he's like,
what the fuck are you guys doing?
You know,
I'm nine.
He's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
You could have killed somebody.
What the fuck?
Why want to just like toys and you know
what I mean?
And,
and his mom comes out freaking out and
they didn't know that we did it.
And My pops was something,
you know,
you've got to understand this,
life that here this is serious.
You got to understand this guy didn't
know that you,
you're playing web.
So it kind of freaked me out.
And then,
um,
I went on one hunting trip and I had 22
and he kicked me in the shoulder.
Pretty good.
22 kicks you and I'm not a 2012 gates.
12 beds.
Yeah.
So yeah.
No,
it was like,
what?
That's like saying,
man,
I shot this slingshot one time.
I broke my hand up.
No.
Yes.
12 gauge shotgun and it kicked me pretty
hard.
And so I just kind of lost interest.
But you know,
that was,
it was a long ass time ago.
Suzanne from honey,
honey and wants to go pig hunting.
Yeah.
So down she keeps bringing it up.
She's like,
why don't we go with Joe Rogan when we
go on pig hunting?
Yeah,
she's totally down to do it.
Definitely.
You know,
and my boy Mike,
where he,
that's what he does all the time.
It was outside of,
um,
a little
outside of Austin.
He's always gone sending me photos,
sending me videos and,
well,
in Austin,
like outside of Texas,
they have a giant problem with pigs.
They have to hunt them.
You can,
you can go to town on them.
They're everywhere.
Yeah.
They have no limits.
You can do it.
They do it from helicopters.
I mean,
they have,
they have a whole business called Hella
hunting where they take people up in,
in helicopters and they're shooting pigs
because it's the only way to eradicate
them from farms because there's so many
of them and they do billions of dollars
worth of damage just in Texas in crop
destruction every year there are wild.
I mean,
there's not,
there's not enough mountain mines and
there's no wolves to kill them and
realize there were so dangerous to,
oh,
they're very dangerous.
The big ones especially,
they'll fuck you up.
That's what I heard.
That's why I said,
why I don't go out there.
They'll fuck you up.
They Killed The dad and game of,
right.
The first king,
the original king,
the one who,
uh,
her husband,
the chick who was fucking her brother
and the game of thrones,
the hot blonde lady.
Her husband died because,
uh,
he got killed by a,
by a pig.
Wait,
is this in the show?
I don't know the shell game of throne.
Not Real life.
You didn't,
I mean in the movie he died from a wild
boar,
but they get fucking big too.
I mean,
a 400 pound wild heart is not uncommon.
That's real.
I never seen with them in real life.
They're crazy.
Look and they're all black and they have
long snouts in their tusks come out.
They have these white tusks.
Like when you see when it real life,
you're like,
oh,
you hear him in real life.
First time I ever went pig hunting,
I was with my friend Steve Rinella and
we're on this farm or this a ranch.
It's not far away from here.
It's huge.
Biggest ranch in California,
270,000 acres.
It's called the home ranch.
And um,
we were walking down this road and we
heard some snaps and some noises in the
bushes,
like it's really thick brush.
And then we heard these pigs fighting
with each other and they were like
Damon's mass eye and they're like no
more than 30 yards,
20 yards away from us.
They're like right there and they're
duking it out in the,
and like these are monsters man.
They sound like monsters.
It freaked me out more than honey bears
more than hunting elk but not more than
elk.
Elk is probably the biggest freak out
cause they scream,
they day bugle and they like a thousand
pounds and they look majestically they
have trees growing out of their head.
These giant antlers.
And then did you see the antlers that
are in the front there over by the front
door is locked in.
That's elk,
those,
that's like a thousand pound animal with
these gigantic,
I mean there they're immense,
immense majestic animals.
Those are the biggest freak outs.
Just cause you feel like you're,
you're hunting some mystical creature.
Where do you find those?
Those were into home ranch two.
One of them was one of those was from to
hone ranch.
One of them was from Colorado,
you know,
rising.
But the pig thing is,
uh,
it's actually look at that fucking
thing,
the size of that thing.
11 year old hunter bags,
a 1050 pound wild boar.
What the fuck?
First of all with a pistol,
this is a perspective shot,
which is actually kind of important
because like that boy is way behind that
thing.
He's not like right next to it.
So if he's behind it by just,
you know,
six or seven feet and the camera's on
the ground,
they're shooting at an eye level.
It makes it look a lot bigger than it
really is.
That's how they do it.
Um,
so,
but a thousand pounds is a fucking
thousand pounds.
That's a giant ass pig.
If you ever seen Hogzilla have I seen
it?
If you've seen the images of Hogzilla,
have you heard of this?
This is like one of the biggest wild
pigs who was ever killed.
It was a,
I believe it was in Georgia.
Yeah.
Is that,
did they have a photo of Hogzilla check?
There's one.
It's hanging there.
That one right there,
Jeremy.
Look at the size of the one that's
hanging next to this guy.
Look at the fucking size.
That thing.
So that's not a perspective shot.
That guy standing right next to that
thing.
What?
Yeah.
What first of all are those his balls up
a top.
Cause if that's his balls.
Respect.
That's a crazy sack.
That's like a couple of watermelons and
an old ladies.
Pantyhose.
What?
It's a giant fucking giant balls.
How big was it?
Over a thousand pounds?
Yeah.
No,
I know.
Wildly considered widely.
Originally it was widely considered a
hoax.
Hmm.
Well they,
what happens is they take domestic pigs
are one of the few animals that morph
automatically when they get out into the
wild.
Like if you have a pig and he's your
buddy and you let them loose out in the
forest,
they change physically.
Their nose gets longer,
their hair gets shaggier and their teeth
grow along or their tusks grow and their
behavior changes.
They go feral and they go feral really
quickly.
I think within like a couple of months
they start physical transformation.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
they're weird animal like wild boars and
wild pigs.
Like do you see a wild boar?
Like dark hair,
thick scrubby and then you see a pig
like at a farm.
Same species.
Same animal,
which is fucking nuts there that it's
all one genus.
It's called [inaudible].
That's the type of animal it is and they
can interbreed with each other.
They're the same thing and that's why
when you go see wild pigs like domestic
pigs that get loose and they become
feral and then they start breeding in
the wild.
They the,
they're black,
they're black.
They have a thick,
thick coat on the,
around where their neck area is because
they fight and they tear each other
apart.
So all around like from their face down
to like a,
where their heart is on their chest is
super thick,
thick,
hide like the thickest fuck like a shoe,
like the bottom of a shoe.
It's incredible how thick it is.
So um,
people that hunt them,
you have to be careful like with bows
and arrows that you don't hit them in
that area.
Cause like if you have a weak bow know,
pulling back a lot of weight with a
really sharp Arrow,
he won't even go through them.
Do you use a bow?
Sometimes?
Yeah,
man,
I had no idea is there's this girl,
she works with this hat shop and uh,
I walked in and she's got this pet
fucking pigs.
I could just imagine that thing like
getting loose for a couple of months.
Like have you seen my,
was it a potbelly pig?
One of those little ones?
Uh,
yeah.
Is that the same deal?
No,
I don't think so.
I think at potbelly pigs or like a,
like a Chore Chihuahua,
the Chihuahua,
the reality of domestic dogs is that
domestic dogs all share,
uh,
genetics with a,
which means somehow or another,
we don't exactly know how they did it,
but through selective breeding,
a wolf became a Chihuahua.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I was having this conversation with a
buddy of mine in Australia of about how
a Chihuahua became a Chihuahua.
And what did he say we could,
we didn't know.
Oh,
we were just like,
that's how fucking crazy is that.
Well,
there's no clear map.
It's not like,
you know,
like a lagger,
to lager is like a line mates with a
tiger.
It makes a logger.
Just bad ass.
Yeah.
Pretty bad as well.
They're also,
they're so big because they want,
it's either a,
I think it's a male lion and a female
tiger and,
or maybe a male tigers and female line,
but it has to be that specific
combination.
And what happens is when that
combination takes place,
they don't receive the gene that
regulates size.
So they keep growing.
Yeah.
They're sort of,
they're enormous.
They're way bigger than a lion and way
bigger than a tiger.
Like laggers are enormous.
They,
they don't even seem real.
That's why they were in Napoleon
dynamite's favorite animal.
Yeah.
Classic.
A classic by the way.
But see,
that makes sense.
Right?
Align mates with a tiger,
you can see that they have similarities
in their features.
Gotcha.
But,
um,
chihuahuas and all domestic dogs,
we don't really know.
We,
there's a lot of speculation and they
believe that wolves became friendly with
people because we're feeding them and
then they become more docile.
I,
there was a radio lab podcast that
talked about breeding foxes and within a
decade they had killed,
they were breeding foxes and they would
kill any fox that showed any sort of
aggression or any and that there was
trying to be dominant with a growl at
people that any,
any,
uh,
any unfavorable characteristics,
they killed them.
And within 10 years,
the genes change to the point where all
the foxes had droopy ears.
Their jaws became less masculine,
they became smaller,
their behavior completely changed.
They all became like a domestic pet.
Within 10 years,
they'd literally became a different
thing.
And so the thought is that this is what
happened with wolves and that wolves
being around campfires with people like
primitive printer of people tens and
20,000,
40,000 years ago,
that we slowly but surely started having
relationships with these animals where
they would protect us from the other
wolves because we would feed them.
And so they would become more docile and
more,
um,
more dependent upon us.
So they would,
uh,
they would be,
they would give in,
you know,
they would,
they would be submissive to us and so
their ears started to flop like a dog's
ear and you know,
they became less aggressive.
They would respond to people,
you could train them and teach them to
hunt with you cause they got a reward
out of being a part of the community of
people.
And then you would raise him from the
time they're puppies and they'd be even
more inclined to go like that.
So someone find wolf puppies and raise
them so they would imprint on people and
be even more likely to exhibit those
behaviors.
Kind of heat for you hanging out with,
to become a Chihuahua gay folk?
Mostly some Mexicans.
Um,
I think,
I think chihuahuas are just,
it's just like thousands of years of
that shit,
you know,
only selecting the smaller ones,
only selecting the most docile,
the most diminutive features.
It's a good question now.
Yeah.
You know,
when you get freaky with it,
the real argument is that,
um,
it's very similar in fact to human
beings.
Human beings are the only animals that
vary as much in their appearance as
dogs.
Like you had Shaquille o'neal and you've
got bridget the midget.
Those are both humans,
right?
How is bridget the midget or any or Brad
Williams,
how anybody who's got dwarfism,
how are they different than an English
bulldog?
Right?
Yeah.
In a way.
I mean,
it's some sort of a strange change in
the body.
And I don't mean this in any
disrespectful way,
I'm just trying to be completely
objective about the physical form of
these people.
You know,
I'm not saying that people purposely
make dwarfs,
but I'm saying that the physical
characteristics that differences in,
uh,
an English bulldog and a wolf,
and that's very like the difference in
Karl Malone and Brad Williams.
I mean there,
those are both humans and they both
could pregnant in pregnant,
the same woman,
like if a woman had a baby with Karl
Malone and then a woman had a baby with
a dwarf,
like right afterwards,
she still mean she can get pregnant from
both of them and have a baby from both
of them.
And potentially the same genetic
characteristics could be passed down
live.
The less likely with the dwarf.
But I mean,
this is incredible when you think about
the variation of human beings.
We can get a little,
a tiny,
like a 90 pound Asian lady,
and then you can have Sabrina Williams,
this super athlete with giant muscles
and just ridiculous explosive ability.
Well,
they're both female humans.
You know,
it's sort of like a,
like a golden lab and a rottweiler.
There's a both dogs,
but they're massively different
characteristics.
Right?
And that's why like really nutty
conspiracy people believe that human
beings are created by aliens and that
much in the same way that human beings,
uh,
engineered dogs and change the shape and
selectively bred them to the point where
they became these little chihuahuas.
That's what aliens did with human
beings.
They came down,
they found some chimpanzees and some
lower hominids and started injecting
their DNA into him.
And slowly but surely created a series
of different styles of,
of human being.
I've heard this before,
but with the vote with the,
but with the dog
comparison.
Yeah.
I don't know man.
I don't know either.
And I'm not,
I don't,
I don't buy the,
uh,
alien thing.
I think it's much more likely it was
just different climates and different
parts of the world.
There were isolated from each other.
And so I think you think he's like,
you know,
built bread,
adapt to your situation.
Yeah,
sure.
no doubt.
You know,
I mean,
there's,
there's characteristics that animals
exhibit that similar animals and other,
uh,
other climates don't like African
elephants for example.
They have enormous ears because it
displaces heat.
Large surface areas displace heat
better.
It's also why a lot of African men are
very tall,
very tall and long because it's,
it's easier displace heat over large
surface area,
right?
Yeah.
So like Asian elephants of different
ears than African elephants do.
Right.
Wooly mammoths of much smaller ears
because they were dealing with cold,
cold climates.
Whereas elephants,
you know,
in Africa when they're in the hot
savannah's they have these giant ass
fucking he hears.
That makes sense.
I mean,
speaking from my thoughts and my
personal experience,
I'm definitely much better off in warmer
climates than I am in cold mountains.
Are you it feel it can't do it,
man.
Can't do it.
Don't you get used to it though?
I mean,
no,
no.
I just feel it in your bones.
Yeah.
I don't like it.
Like,
I don't like this.
I need to get over away from this.
You know,
like if it's hot,
I'm like,
okay,
guy's cool,
but not cold is like,
Eh,
eh.
Yeah.
Get away.
We'll also growing up in Austin work,
it's hot as fuck.
Yeah,
definitely.
So yeah,
I did the New York thing couldn't deal
with winters.
No Dude,
no,
cause I'm thinking about,
I'm thinking about all the times where I
busted ass and you know,
so it's like walking across the street
and I stepped in and what I think is
snow and it's like underneath is like a
foot of water and you know,
I'm just walking around and you know,
I've got one wet foot and I'm supposed
to be going to some fucking event or
something and I go to dinner or do
whatever.
I just,
I can't,
I can't do it.
I mean I can,
you know,
I don't want to sound like a pussy or
anything,
but I can't do it.
Well you can,
but you don't want to.
There it is.
I don't want to,
I fucking don't want to.
Why should you have to?
I don't.
That's why I'm [inaudible] options.
Exactly.
Like if the whole world was New York
City,
you could do it.
You could do it.
It's definitely better than not living.
No,
that's true.
That's very true.
I could do it,
but you know that there's a better spot.
Right.
I could adapt if I didn't know any
better.
I get it down,
but here you are in the best spot.
Exactly.
When comes to weather,
nobody can fuck with La.
That's true.
That's very true.
That's why so many of us,
it's what Jamie's here.
Look at him.
He's like,
he's from Columbus,
Ohio.
Really?
Yeah.
Columbus,
Ohio gives New York City that eight out
in the breaks.
As far as,
that's a pool term,
like it's a spot.
It's a spot of your plane.
10 Ball.
He gives some of the eight out in the
breaks.
That means if they spot,
if they win,
they can win.
If they make the eight ball,
the nine ball or the 10 ball and they
could break every touching,
that's eight out in the breaks.
That's a considerable,
considerable handicap.
Gotcha.
I would say pull a little bit,
but I don't.
Columbia,
I've been to Columbus before.
We've got this cool little venue.
I played that.
Columbus is great.
Yeah,
it's nice.
It's a great town.
They're cool people.
They're man.
It's a fun,
it's a fun town.
I liked Columbus a lot and haven't spent
a lot of times now about,
he definitely had a good time.
I haven't been there since.
I shot my special there in 2009 that's
what Dick I am.
Where was that in one southern theater.
Once that the uh,
oh that's right.
That's right.
Jamie knows my schedule better than me
when I started working with,
that's ridiculous.
Jamie,
how do I,
how do you know this?
And I don't know this.
That was like 2011 or 12 right?
To tell them 12 yeah.
Columbus is a cool town.
That's like my favorite town in a,
in Ohio.
Ooh.
Where else is there in Ohio?
Like did you Cleveland Cleveland's not
bad.
Cleveland.
Cincinnati is fun,
but Cincinnati that bullshit you,
he's got the Cincinnati airport in
Kentucky.
I don't like that.
Why?
Well,
because it's insecure.
The Kentucky people are insecure.
They should call it the fucking Kentucky
airport.
Cause that's what it is.
God dammit.
Toledo,
Cincinnati assholes claim your city.
Wait,
but how does that even exactly.
The Cincinnati Airport is actually in
Kentucky.
But to get people to fly into Kentucky
is problematic because people have,
they have massive prejudice against
Kentucky.
Man.
It just sounds like hillbillies were as
Cincinnati is like wk Rp,
you know,
it's like a Loni Anderson and fucking
everybody's having a good time.
Right.
You know,
Cincinnati sounds like a nice city,
right?
Well it's fucking right next door to
Kentucky.
So close that you land in Kentucky and
then you drive to Cincinnati.
So they name the fucking Cincinnati
airport.
This Kentucky airport.
That's pretty good.
One sneaky sneaky mother fuckers.
They did it for people like us.
I've never going to go to Kentucky.
I fucking got me.
I swore I'd never come into this buts.
But meanwhile there's like Louisville
where everybody goes like,
it doesn't make any sense.
You know,
with the Kentucky Derby is in
Louisville,
right?
Yeah.
See that's like everybody goes there,
but it's one of those quaint southern
destinations.
You know,
I liked the word quaint make too.
Yeah.
Ah,
I spent a little bit of time running
around.
They're fun.
Like the,
um,
it's the wildest crowds and kind of like
in that area.
And so for me,
I think that's interesting for me.
I wonder why.
I wonder why that is.
Booze.
Uh,
I think,
yeah,
I mean,
boots happens everywhere,
but I feel like,
yeah,
people really have a good time.
Well,
when I started going on the road a lot
in the 90s,
is when I really understood Nascar.
They got never got Nascar.
I'm like,
cool,
the fuck is watching this.
It's not that I didn't like car racing.
It's like,
who the fuck is watching these people go
around in a circle?
And then I would see how big it was.
I would read statistics.
I was like,
Bull Shit.
These fucking statistics are all made
up.
No one's watching this.
And then,
uh,
I did a radio station,
um,
I wanna say it was in Atlanta.
I don't remember where it was,
but I remember,
uh,
it was in the south and the guy was
like,
yeah,
did you see the race this weekend?
Man,
Dale Jr's really fucking putting it to
them,
but me.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
And like Nascar,
Tony Stewart,
and he starts naming all these people.
I'm like,
I don't know who the fuck you're talking
about.
And he was flabbergasted that I did know
who these Nascar people were.
And then I didn't know who won the look
and talent cus Calusa five,
five,
five 60 or whatever the fuck name of the
race it was.
He was,
he was flabbergasted.
And I was like,
how many people know?
So then we had people call in like that
knew a lot about nascar while I was on
the air.
I was like,
you guys know a lot about Nascar.
How many people?
We watch it every weekend and they'll be
like going crazy about nascar.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
So this is a geographical for go
cultural thing that I'm just not privy
to.
I just don't understand it.
Mm.
Yeah.
Uh,
we got a little bit of taste of that and
in Texas kind of bled over a little bit,
but Austin has a formula one race that's
very new.
But how is it,
how old is that?
Well,
I guess,
I don't know.
I'm new enough.
Yeah,
a few years have passed I guess.
But yeah,
the f one,
uh,
that's the shit,
man.
That's a different kind of racing.
And that's my style of racing.
I love watching Formula One cars.
It's turns and craziness and strategy
and you know,
that's,
that seems like some crazy shit.
Yeah.
I can get more into that,
but yeah,
I didn't know shit about Nascar either.
Yeah.
But,
you know,
different things.
It's definitely a cultural deal.
I was driving through,
you know,
Alabama and you know,
the south and everything and it's
theirs,
you know,
uh,
tracks and everything,
you know,
for amateurs and it's,
it's just like a big culture,
I guess.
You know,
it's a big deal for those folks.
And they say that all came out of
souping up their cars for moonshine
runs.
I can believe it.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
Right?
I get to get in and get out of there.
Yeah.
Get this money,
get the six,
which all came from the same thing that
we're dealing with,
with,
with psychedelics suppression.
Right.
I mean,
suppression creates diamonds.
I mean that's,
that's what created that kind of racing
is people trying to figure out a way to
get the fuck away from cops.
So they made cars that drove faster,
handled better,
and they could just get away from cops.
And that was the whole dukes of hazard.
That's why they had the general Lee.
They weren't involved in braces.
They were running away from cops.
They had some crazy souped up.
Fuck it.
That's why they couldn't have guns.
They always had bows and arrows because
the cops had taken their,
their ability to have a firearm away.
When you're a felon in this country,
you can't own a gun anymore.
Right.
I understand.
A little bit.
This podcast turned weird,
right?
Yeah.
It was a weird one.
A little bit.
It was a good one though,
man.
Yeah.
So where are you performing next and now
how can,
how can people see your work?
Where can they find out?
Um,
we're performing,
doing something for the grammys.
Oh,
cool.
Um,
the 15th of February,
we're doing a tribute to the legendary
bb king.
Beautiful Chris Stapleton and Bonnie
Raitt.
I wouldn't be doing what I was doing if
it weren't for guys like bb King,
you know,
so that's been,
it'll be cool to,
to be able to show him some love there.
And then we just hit the road,
man.
We're going everywhere.
Um,
your website?
Yeah,
Gary Clark Jr Carr.
And uh,
you're active on twitter.
I see you're on twitter all the time.
There's all these little,
oh,
I'm not as active as,
as people say I should be.
When are you going to be in this area
where I could come see you man.
Uh,
what are we going to be?
Um,
is there anything on there?
Does it say anything there about a
California?
Yeah,
we'll be doing coachella.
That's uh,
that's about it.
Uh,
last time we did a three nights at the
fondant December,
so we kind of at the what?
At the Fonda.
Oh,
where's that?
A Hollywood.
Okay.
So yeah,
we did that one and I think we're not,
we're not going to be around here for a
little while.
Well,
there's a man.
Anything you got going on?
Anything.
If you ever want it promoted.
Do you need any help tweeting it and
put,
come on here anytime you want.
You've got an open invite.
Thanks man.
I'm happy you're in our town here and I
hope you enjoy it and extend you as much
hospitality as possible.
Appreciate it.
And I'm a big fan man.
I love your music.
I listen to it.
I was listening to it on the way over
here,
man.
I'll show you.
Check the likewise,
man,
I've been following you for a long time.
Damn.
Look at that.
That's my playlist on the way over here,
sir.
I appreciate it.
So,
uh,
much love Sir and respect Gary Clark Jr.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back tomorrow with Tom.
Papa.
See you soon.
Much love.
Bye Bye.
Thank you.
Hmm.